thank you
wow
[Music]
the point here
hopefully you can see the board
let me know if you can't let me know if
you have a problem seeing the board or
anything
Merry Christmas
foreign
[Music]
good enough
yeah msb6
wow
foreign
[Music]
foreign
lucky
pure luck every game so far
unlock will run out eventually
gradual playing
let's go here
chin up chimp
okay I should probably give up this one
I don't know how he's going to win this
ah he goes G6
no it wasn't to me
[Music]
okay he always plays Berlin though it's
kind of weird he always seems to play
the Berlin
but okay I always beat him in this line
too
you guys shouldn't have given up the pun
but if he takes it
the night here
foreign
no oh okay it's fine
what am I doing
no oh
[Laughter]
relax relax
that Rook was hanging right there
this is actually a theory
okay that was a mistake
foreign
[Music]
foreign
I rushed it a little bit I had plenty of
time
I should still try to Swindle him
I'm getting
no it won't it won't it won't extend
sorry let me at least try to do it after
this game
it won't seem to join it
like I literally cannot like it's it's
because of the way my
okay I I need to focus I'm sorry
now you can probably be able to see it
now you should probably see it
oh
goodbye
Ali Riza
Oh I thought I Mouse look for a second
what am I doing why am I
I don't know why I sacked this one
this is a total dead end
oh
I guess it works
wait
you doing in here
no I'm blundered that pawn that's okay
it's okay no no no
watering all my Pawns
yeah actually
no this one I'm gonna lose
I promise I lose a lot of end games to
him
okay let's see if I can get active
I'm literally losing all my phones every
one of them
counter play of some sort
not really I have a blockade though
ah he didn't blender Maiden one
stalemate still we have to set up a
stalemate of some sort here at least a
try it would be nice
just to try
our Targaryen
crap
score is five to three
it's a mouse look
I think that's enough
foreign
I just put up the garbage here
oh
okay I guess he lets me keep the pawn
that last game I should have totally won
like I was just up upon
basically no comp
or up in exchange rather
missing
thank you
hello alireza you gonna make a move or
no
is she gonna beat me here
[Music]
like flag Angelus flag flag of its flag
of its Flex keys
if I have good moves
there's 95.
wait why did I why didn't I take on e4
oh I guess it is a move
guys the score is six to three it's
easier for me to play this way
I will announce the score after every
game all right
it's not the end of the world
it's tilted but see guys the problem is
when Ali Rez is tilted he's like still
freaking good
but not good enough enough yatch
Bang
I feel like I'm a tenant's umpire La
forty you know how tennis Empire is
always you know low 40. the game not all
game Djokovic it's like they exaggerate
their accent
game not all
game Rebecca Harris
Rebecca
Rebecca Harris
crap
shouldn't have given away all these
pawns but it's okay
sword
the chorus
crap I should have taken of course The
Rook
Rebecca
foreign
Ty
game not all
okay he's lagging clearly or something
[Music]
he's clearly lagging
or is it me is it my internet folks
jokaris
what would sensor stock think of this
move
you just gave me freaking time odds
now he's gonna beat me
okay what is that
no no no no no no no no no this is
terrible lady but he shouldn't have
taken my Rook
um
come on Daniel
foreign
like an idiot
son sir
[Music]
I have to say that was impressive by
alireza
that was impressive that was a good end
game technique eight four
that was an easy win for me but of
course
that's a budget
foreign
somehow it's almost harder to play when
you're when you have these time odds
it's weird
psychologically it's like you feel like
you need to punish them
so you start playing less objectively
I
Leonard a piece
is there really nothing here
all right come on
wow okay let's try the second
[Music]
eight five
losing the thread here
okay maybe if I can force the queen
trade
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
nine six nine six
foreign
foreign
[Music]
nine seven
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
11. 11 7.
12 7.
I'm sorry that's the move
that's the move that I play I'm not
trying to be dirty there
I'm not trying to be dirty there I
literally played the Deferred exchange
like that is one of my main weapons I
swear to God I wasn't trying to be dirty
there
it's a nice bonus not gonna lie but
foreign
foreign
yeah it is like a pickup game
just playing good old-fashioned bullet
match two friends
two friends playing a good old school
dog fight you know what I'm saying
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
thank you
foreign
nice
nice
actually not over yet
foreign
[Music]
this is a win as you guys know
okay
make your chest Dojo live playing a
little match with Ellie Reza here late
at night
he's not tilted guys he's playing well
Jesus Christ
wow
foreign
s are easy
I know they can be taken for granted
because you can turn this at the drop of
a hat
which is exactly what he's trying to do
yeah but he takes and goes a3m busted
missed it
no oh see I lost my discipline there
I lost my discipline there
I thought the it was the wrong color
actually for some reason I thought
yeah I just I was stupid 15 8.
I really didn't want to draw
yeah the true name one I'm sure it's the
turning point at 15 8.
yep totally the turning point I'm
positive let's see let's see how much of
a turning point it is
now we're about to find out let's see
thanks for thanks for uh your vote of
confidence y'all
really
all right Riley
okay this is a draw
I'm not going to experiment here
no I know I'm kidding
I
know
I gotta give some of y'all a hard time
now I'm gonna get flagged
bro
foreign
15 and a half to eight and a half
okay this one's a disaster
but if he takes it
it's not so clear are you blundered A7
and I didn't take it
200 A7
restoring the material equality
but now I need to get my queen out of
there
okay let's just go
that was a dumb move
yeah I am starting to lose the third I
guess the guy's right
I need a miracle here
I need something to go my way
foreign
I needed one I got one
sixteen and a half eight and a half
five thousand from Kami Holy Cannoli
come on man you didn't have to do that 5
000 bits I see
that's what we're talking about thank
you thank you thank you damn girl
Hey where's the mate
yeah here I'm busted
16 and a half nine and a half
foreign
foreign
oh no
ugh 16 and a half ten and a half okay
last couple guys then I gotta go to bed
I have commentary
as much as I want to continue I need
that
I was planning to do a speedrun game as
well
yeah I'm tired it's been a long day
eventful day
it's tough to play alirez when you're
like this tired
it's not an excuse for the crappy play
though
foreign
no yes
gotcha I think I blundered that huh
very poor guys very poor
foreign
foreign
and a half eleven and a half
thank you
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
I'm running out of gas
[Music]
Jesus
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
oh my gosh I need to stop I'd say
totally out of gas
[Music]
yeah well it's 4am and I play chess all
day so I mean yeah I'm in a blunder a
little bit
you know I'm playing for Russia
but I don't know what's expected you
know
I'm doing my best
yeah mister it's turning point we'll
[ __ ] see how about that
how about that
we shall find out where's the turning
point
[Music]
I can't lose this one
that's exactly what I'm doing
let's choke it
or not
how about that like that
let's see let's see whether that was the
turning point or not
we shall see
just not playing with the same energy
that I was at the start of the match
unfortunately
and he is playing better and better
I mean he's playing actually like
ridiculously well
[Music]
I mean it's crazy he's playing instantly
he's finding all the moves
stuff
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
bye
okay stop playing C5
let's go over the solid line
up
don't worry I'm not actually angry at
the turning point I'm just bumping
myself up I hope that's okay
I need to bump myself up somehow you
know what I'm saying
otherwise I'm just starting to lose
games and then it gets annoying
I just I'm just annoyed when people
abandon ship after one freaking get lost
all right I'm not who I used to be
I ain't gonna tilt
against cellular as I'm playing every
game full strength
[Music]
they are who we thought they were yeah
exactly
I remember that
that's a hilarious rant
okay now he's tilted
he does tilt really really quickly
that's the one thing
one area where I think I have an edge
over him
[Music]
what
girl
what you doing girl
wait he wants a truck
oh my God that's almost made but it's
not we win again
[Music]
ending that score
am I doing
foreign
foreign
[Music]
no come on Daniels foreign
[Music]
let's go
guys bullet
this bullet just neither of us has any
expectation that the other is not going
to do this
I'm on a winning streak and I'm going to
continue that winning streak at all
costs
22 and a half to 15 and a half
Rebecca leading
they are who we thought they were
foreign
foreign
whatever I mean that's actually is a
draw that position is a draw
there's no way that works
if this is what he does he always sacks
an exchange and then he somehow just
like wins all my Pawns
literally sevens every time
foreign
how did I manage to lose that one
that was the true Talent
okay guys so that was 40 games we'll
probably go to 50.
foreign
and I clean a set of straps
foreign
[Music]
crap I almost did it
come on
foreign
to give away but I'm still winning
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
should have stops and I had like a 10K
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this idea now with my sleeve
foreign
for the subs game there
yeah but I'm gonna lose
the problem
[Music]
like I sacked the night there to avoid
a position where I can't find the moves
working
and it's a terrible move that's another
terrible move yeah this is
a disaster
okay I love Z4
foreign
foreign
foreign
oh my gosh I'm not even paying attention
to what he's doing
all right guys last game
I might have guessed
I'll continue Upstream I need to focus
foreign
all right guys I'm gonna call it you win
the match 25 24 hope you enjoyed
but I'm gonna get going see everybody
Demar thanks for hanging out everybody
[Music]